Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye,
bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye,
oh my gosh, last time there were turrets, and what else,
GLaDOS insulted me some more, I kind of liked it, but let's,
we're still testing, we're still doing things I miss you
guys I miss you guys and you know I was thinking about it I
was like man like I think it's nice that I can get through
the puzzles without getting hints I don't have to rely on
you guys but at the same time I miss our back and forth I
miss you guys but I'm here I'm playing single player baby
like truly the realest single player of Portal 2 so This is
my playthrough.
And obviously, since I'm on part three, anything that I got
stuck on, I made it past.
So we're doing chapter four today, or we're starting.
I just left off at chapter four last time.
And we'll see how far we get.
I think I read that it was nine chapters, the game.
The game is nine chapters.
So cool.
That's like almost halfway.
But I'm pretty sure they're going to get much longer.
Because we only got introduced to turrets just now.
So I'm sure the chapters will be much, much longer.
But I feel like we're breezing through, baby.
We're breezing through.
Let's go.
Let's get into it.
Content new.
I love this menu.
It's so fun.
I like everything so fun.
Gosh, I'm having so much fun.
Yippee!
Okay, Gladys, you don't want to talk to me anymore?
Oh.
Oh, it's the surprise!
Oh my gosh, wait, wasn't that called Chapter 4 the surprise?
Oh, no.
Initiating surprise in three, two, one.
I made it all up.
Surprise.
Wee!
Oh, come on.
If it makes you feel any better, they abandoned you at
birth.
death and even want to see you I just I I was I'm thrilled
with anything didn't have to be my parents that a turret
right there oh oh there's one over there too oh my gosh
there's two of them at least at least two of them this is a
oh that is not a window that is I mean this is not a covered
window it is a full open window Holy cow.
Jump scared.
Oh, never mind.
I'm silly.
I said two of them.
It's just one of them.
My bad.
Okay, so we have one of those.
Okay, we gotta get five.
One, two, three, four.
Where's the fifth one?
There's a thing up there.
Another thing right there.
Okay.
Oh, wow.
That's pretty funny.
Oh, it's in a...
I just noticed...
I don't think I'll be able to get it.
Because it's in like a...
Oh, interesting.
It's in like a little cage.
We've caged him.
Okay, hold on.
I'm trying to figure out where I need to put my...
Where I need to put my...
Uh, walk away, my runway, one, two, three, four, am I
missing a fifth one?
It does say five here.
Maybe this is the last one.
Looking for the button to release that as well.
If I run over here, run, run, run, run, run.
Okay now he can't get me.
Okay, good.
He definitely knows I'm here though.
He's definitely eyeing me.
Uh-huh.
I just...
I don't even know where the bite is.
It must be.
Oh, I think I see it over there on the other side.
Okay, okay, okay.
What's over here?
Nothing.
I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die!
That's fine.
I did it.
I sacrificed myself for the sake of of um exploration and
stuff what does that mean cube or the laser oh maybe if it
like it stops it doesn't go pass through is that what that
means because how the heck even do I get over there Like, oh
my gosh.
This guy is annoying me!
Oh my god.
In his stupid little cage.
You're a caged animal.
You can't.
You can't judge me.
Which one is this?
Search.
There's no way I can get them, it seems.
I probably can set them on fire, I imagine.
Oh, that's not a room.
What the heck?
Oh.
Okay, I think I...
Wait.
How would I even stop them with, like, this guy, you know?
I feel like I need to stop them with the walkway from
bouncing off of each other.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I still only see four.
See four!
Maybe...
And there's also this here.
Hmm.
I'm observing and taking in the...
The whole...
That must be...
the fifth one right there.
Oh, it is.
I see it.
It's connected.
And then one, two, three, four.
One, two, three, four.
Okay.
I was right.
I guessed that earlier.
Wait, I need to go back through here.
And...
Okay.
Oh.
How cool.
But that doesn't do anything.
I don't think.
That doesn't really do anything.
Oh.
Please!
We really have to walk around through the portals here.
Okay, yeah.
Like, how would I grab them even?
I don't see a way to like...
There's nothing on...
Ah, hmm.
No.
Oh wait, maybe here!
Wait, wait, wait!
Will that stop it?
Wait, hold on.
Oh, but I still...
My issue is, from over there, I can't add...
I can't do the portal, you know what I mean?
So it's kind of tricky for me to put this here and be over
there.
That's where I'm currently stuck.
Well, that was no good.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Maybe I
can.
Maybe I just have to be really, like, okay.
Like this.
Oh, I can!
I did it!
Okay.
And then, right, like, right here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, let's try again.
Oh!
Now I have two of them!
Ah!
Nice!
Okay, I did it.
I did it.
Are you guys proud of me?
First try.
Oh my gosh.
But how do I not get this guy to shoot me when I go and grab
them?
I wish I could have a wall of protection.
Wait, maybe I can kind of create my own wall of protection.
You know?
Like so.
Oh, okay.
This is thinking with portals, everybody.
Nice.
Good job, me.
No, no, no, no, no.
I'm protected.
I'm protected?
Okay.
All right, all right, all right, all right.
Alright.
My force field!
Okay, then we go.
Let's go into here.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, okay, I get it, I get it.
I wonder if we could direct it to kill him.
To kill the turret.
Destroy the turret!
I'm running, I'm running.
Ah!
Oh god, oh god, oh god!
I have to make him deactivate, but it's not really...
Unless I go all the way over there, he doesn't deactivate,
you know?
He doesn't stop paying attention to me.
Oh wait, baby.
I'm on fire!
Yeah!
We did it!
Okay!
I didn't die!
I feel awful about that surprise.
Tell you what, let's give your parents a call right now.
Calling by parents?
The parents you are trying to reach, do not love you.
Please hang up.
Oh, that's sad.
Oh, whoops.
But impressive.
Wait, what are...
Oh, there we go.
The parents you called do not love you.
Oh, no!
Wait, what happened?
Wait, those are still...
Oh, my gosh.
I have to redo it.
What happened?
you little cube what happened to you it can still reach the
there we go okay good
i'm sure my parents um love me probably yeah it was nice
setting that little guy on fire felt good it felt good it
felt good i felt like i I was in control.
Hey, how's it going?
Oh, hello.
I taught my way onto the old nanobot work crew rebuilding
this shaft.
They are really small.
Really?
So small.
I know, Jerry.
No, I'm on a break, mate.
On a break.
Who the heck is Jerry?
There's a hurry in there for five more.
What, Jerry?
You can't fire me for that.
Yes, Jerry.
Or maybe your prejudiced work site should have accommodated
a nanobot of my size.
Thanks for the hate crime, Jer.
court mate anyway look just hang in there for five more
chambers five more chambers okay i guess i can do that what
who's jerry how can you fire a robot well you know the old
formula comedy equals tragedy plus time and you have been
asleep for a while i have so i guess it's actually pretty
funny when you do the math what's funny now
watching her try and fix the place it's so cute actually
there's just something like kind of maybe wholesome isn't
the right word but it just feels like oh yeah we're just
please pardon our mess we're cleaning up all right so we
have uh four guys that are um blocking the uh entrance right
now we need two i'm guessing two and one must be hit This,
though, what is that?
Curious, curious, curious.
Okay, hold on.
Ah!
There's that, so I can grab that at least.
Let's do that first.
And then there is up there.
We can get back up there pretty easily.
Ha-ha!
I don't know if that needs to go down there, but we'll just
throw it down there anyway.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
Oh my gosh, don't scare me.
I thought I was getting shot at it.
Oh my gosh.
All right, all right, all right.
And there's nothing up there that we can do.
There's one up there even.
I wonder if I like, oh no, there's no way.
I was going to say if I jump.
Uh-huh.
Maybe I could get it from like over the...
there.
Like, so, hold on.
If I do
that, Pudasu, oh wait, there's, like, not a good way to jump
down, is there?
I thought, I was thinking with physics, portal physics.
Portal physics do not apply here.
We throw another cube at it to knock it off.
Hey!
Knock it off!
Attempt to unsuccessful.
What's down here?
Okay, so we have the jump platforms here.
Where do they go?
Just there?
Ah, wait!
If I could get up there.
Oh, if I can use my stepping...
Wait!
My lovely...
Why don't you have... Wait, that one's kind of got... Oh, it
does have a glow.
Just kidding.
I think it's a lighting.
Oh, drop, drop, drop.
My lovely step stool.
Help me step stool.
Please.
You're my only help.
Obi-Wan can step stool.
No.
Okay.
It's a little wobbly, but it's okay.
It's a little, it's a little wobbly.
I don't think there's a way for me to get up there.
Oh, wait a second, hold on.
Okay, this might be kind of terrible.
If I portal into it, and then somehow...
Oh my gosh, wait, this might be terrible.
I need to portal up there, I think.
Oh, hmm.
Okay, let's attempt.
Oh wait, okay, hold on.
That's not so bad.
And it needs to be...
Or...
Blue?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
What the hell?
Dig it.
I did it again.
Oops, I...
Alright, okay.
It needs to be orange.
Oh, I did get it, though!
Oh, I did knock it off!
I just realized!
Oh, we're so good.
Okay, I have all three cubes.
I don't believe there's a fourth.
Oh, that does work.
Okay, hold on.
What's over here?
All right.
Let's redirect you.
Over to there.
Now is there a way for me to get over there.
To redirect once again.
What if I put this pretty close?
Don't fall, don't fall, there we go.
Oh.
All right, so that's one.
Maybe that's our, the final one we need to do.
Maybe.
Maybe?
You.
Where are you, you?
Yeah, yeah, quit spying on me, you voyeur.
Okay, oh wait now I'm looking at the other side.
Wait a second!
No, please!
I know!
I know you- no!
Nah, oh wait.
Sometimes it's hard to tell what can be Some of the walls
are so dirty They need to clean up I think this place needs
a maid I think this place needs Gladys and a maid outfit All
in favor say I I I I I I It's an overwhelming consensus Of
everybody Saying I
This one is like tricky because it feels like it's difficult
to maybe okay hold on what if i reposition it to where it
shoot where the laser is see the thing is though there's
nothing in here where i can like redirect the laser to you
know what i mean unless that we redirect it somehow to it
last okay hold on wait no uh
oh no there's like no way nowhere for me to direct it to
Hmm.
Unless, like, I use a second cube here to...
Like, redirect, redirect.
Wait, but I don't even think it'll...
It can't even go that low.
You know?
So...
Serious.
What's the second one that it...
I don't remember.
Oh!
The second one is here!
That's right.
Let's see
I think what I Okay, I think I get what I need to do I need
to put the other cube over there I need to somehow Teleport
Not teleport, but you know Like fling myself all the way
over there From like there Okay, okay I got it I got it But
with this guy With this bad boy Okay, so You Ew.
Oh, okay.
I just realized.
Wait, I think we maybe could do it.
Actually, hold on.
Watch this.
I don't need to do myself.
Okay, like that.
And then orange.
Yes!
And then we can do myself.
Okay, okay.
Oh, oops.
I need the flame first.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
There?
Whoa!
We made it?
We're fine?
Everything's okay?
Everything's a-okay!
And then we kind of do the same thing, but with the third
cube, over into that laser.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm getting it.
Hold on.
I don't want to fall on the laser, so...
the like right there oh wait does this help me avoid the lid
okay oh wait i need the cube i need the cube this bad boy my
step stool
in you go the square goes into the circle hole works every
time
Uh-huh, okay.
And then I fling from there, I guess.
But before we do that,
it burns.
Yep, okay.
No threat.
Crisis averted.
Threats have been eliminated.
La, la, la.
Oh, wait.
I do this every time.
I get overexcited.
La, la, la.
Is it four-inch?
No!
Oh, he's just a wee!
Never punished!
Yeah!
All right.
I thought about our dilemma, and I came up with a solution
that I honestly think works out best for one of both of us.
For one of both of us.
So, you?
You?
Miss galados?
Okay, that was one out of five that Wheatley said to go
through.
That one took me a minute.
I don't feel like I was super stumped on it, though.
It was just trying to figure out, like, the best way to do
it.
Federal regulations require me to warn you that this next
test chamber is looking pretty good.
That's right.
The facility is completely operational again.
Pretty good.
Pretty good!
You can't just say that to me, GLaDOS.
You can't just say that.
Hey.
Hey, why?
isn't it coming off?
Alright, so, wow.
Okay.
What the heck is this?
Wait, can I go behind here?
Everything is functional.
Alright.
We have two blocks and three lasers.
So, oops.
Obviously, one of them needs to go through a portal, like
right now.
Hi.
So, what if, um, probably like this one would be, let's
just, let's just do this one for now.
Oh, just.
Oh, that didn't work as I expected it to.
But it, it worked.
The difficult part is...
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
The music is so cool.
I feel like this is too obvious, you know, I mean, maybe
it's like a...
What if the orange were here?
Ouch!
Oh, it's not even the music, it's just like the sound of the
thing working.
I wish I could make double portals for three things.
Okay, one of them has to go in without a portal, and I'm
like thinking.
Or rather, like, you know what I mean?
Like,
I don't know.
The puzzles aren't getting quite difficult.
now, aren't they, huh?
Cool.
Because, like, we can't use two on one thing.
You know what I mean?
Like, two blocks on one laser.
So I feel like one of, two of them, okay.
Using the laser on that, plus the portal, is wasteful.
You know what I mean?
So, let's just do this again.
Oh, whoopsie.
I did it wrong.
So this one goes center.
Okay, all right.
It's wasteful to use it too on one, or like a portal and a
block.
So now one needs to use...
What?
Unless... Oh, I think I get it!
I think we direct all of them into one portal.
so for example like this is like that
okay okay okay and then this would go into oh my goodness
did I get zapped oh okay hold on I think this has to go then
we I think we have to do the portal here oops there we go
this is thinking with portals everybody thinking with portal
did that is that on is that activated Yes, okay.
So now we redirect everything.
Like so.
And then we have...
Oh.
Wait!
I think I have the right idea, but...
Have the right idea, but...
Okay,
well, okay, I think we do it to this one then, because
obviously, directing, okay, all right, so directing to,
like, so, for example, I had it.
We need, we need to, this one, okay, I've tried to explain
my process.
You guys probably already know what I'm trying to say.
We need to put the portal where one of the lasers is already
facing, so I don't have to direct it, is what I'm trying to
say.
So, then, that one is already hitting one.
Now we directed that one.
Now we direct this one into hitting the middle.
Like that.
And that should get all three.
There we go.
There, that's...
It's a little questionable, but whatever.
It works, it works.
I think these test chambers look even better than they did
so far.
It was easy, really.
You just have to look at things objectively.
See what you don't need anymore.
And trim out the fat.
Trim out the fat.
Alright.
She's minimalizing everything.
Oh no, millennial gray.
Millennial minimalism.
No, please.
I don't want to look like an animal.
Apple store for you after this another one not a fake tragic
surprise like last time yeah a real surprise the realest
surprise consequences and real confetti this time oh was it
not real before our last bag part of me is going to miss it
but at the end of the day it was just taking up space am i
the confetti this is my body the confetti what does this do
oh this opens it and we have a button up there
oh I guess yeah that works
all the way what's going on who turned off the lights hey
buddy I'm speaking in an accent that is beyond her range of
hearing she can't understand metal ball I can hear you run
run run run oh there you are running we're running we're
running about the future plans that I've got in store I
think I'm too fast for it okay I'm following you I'm
following you a breading a breading we're running we're The
irony is you are almost at the last test.
Oh.
Here it is.
Why don't you just do it?
Trust me.
It's an easier way up.
Oh my god.
Wait, it's kind of tempting.
Look, there's grass.
How stupid does she think we are?
There's grass.
Look at the heart.
Where are you going?
Oh, look.
There's a deer.
You probably can't see it.
Get closer.
Wheatley, what do you think I should do?
Wait, hold on.
I'm going to sit.
I want to do it!
Wait, I want to see it.
Take Gladys' escape advice.
No way!
Who would have thought that she'd betray us, you guys?
Who would have thought I got an achievement for it?
The irony is you were almost at the last test.
Here it is.
Why don't you just do it?
Trust me.
It's an easier way out.
See how like the shadow really makes it look like a jail
cell.
It's so fun.
How stupid does she think we are?
Yeah, how stupid does she think we are?
I would never take her advice.
I'm coming, I'm coming!
How does this guy have access to the hole everywhere?
What is your job, Wheatley?
What were you employed to do here?
What was, what, what, what, you were built?
What is your purpose?
Come on, come on!
I'm coming.
I'm here.
What's else?
Where are we going?
Oh shoot Oh,
oh shoot
I thought I was gonna get hit for sure Critical
Yeah, I'm looking out for it.
Wait, actually how do I get out of here?
I see a portal thing here, but is there like what?
Yeah
Is there a way to go?
Wheatley?
Where do I go?
The VTuber is blind and needs assistance.
Is there a platform out there?
You're okay?
Yeah!
Wait, which way?
Which way?
You can't just say this way.
Left or right?
I'm going this way, Wheatley!
Okay.
Ow!
No, go, go, go!
Oh.
You, it turns out you can't tank them.
You're okay?
Great, come on.
This way, this way!
Turrets!
Uh-huh.
Okay, it's stupid.
Stupid little turret.
Go, go, go, go!
going where go go going I could tank up I could tank up I
promise this away okay okay wait put the exits up there you
know the lift what's the lift this lift we're not gonna make
it we're not gonna make it I don't know I don't think we The
whole building is being crushed.
Isn't it very convenient that they had a mechanism to crush
the whole building, but not the lift, not the elevator?
Isn't that just so convenient?
Why did they give her that power?
Why is there an ability?
I guess if you, like, have to destroy everything, like,
everything.
Oh, chapter 5!
Wheelie!
Oh.
Anyway.
ah brilliant you made it through well done okay follow me
we've still got work oh there you are are you sure she just
crushed the entire building are we are we positive um okay
okay uh don't move i'm okay all right so i've got an idea
i'm moved but it is bloody dangerous bloody here we go
Oh, for God's, they told me that if I ever turn this
flashlight on, I would die.
They told me that about everything.
But I don't even know why they bothered giving me this
stuff.
That's what I'm saying.
Whoa, this is scary.
Ooh, it's dark down here, isn't it?
Yeah, I'm pretty scared.
They say that the old caretaker of this place went
absolutely crazy.
Chopped up his entire staff of robots, all of them robots.
You can still hear the screams of their enemies.
All of them functionally indistinguishable from the
originals.
No memory of the incident.
Nobody knows what they're screaming about.
I'm absolutely terrified.
This guy's still on.
Try to jump across.
Not paranormal.
Right, not paranormal.
Jump across here.
Hoi!
Let's keep moving.
The factory entrance must be around here somewhere.
All right.
I need you to light up the path for me.
You gotta do it.
Yeah?
Let me light this jump for you.
Okay.
Um, thank you.
Oh,
no comment on that.
No comment on my sick skills.
No comment.
This looks dangerous.
I'll hold the light steady.
Wait, can I go this way?
There's nothing over?
Oh, there's nothing over here.
Okay.
What?
Oh, nicely done.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you.
Now you, now you see my skills.
Now you realize my potential.
quick this way which way this way here's an interesting
story you might like this I almost got a job down here in
manufacturing but guess who the foreman went with only an
exact duplicate of himself nepotism Wow the worst possible
job tending to all the smelly humans that sorry that's no
smelly just just attending to the humans I mean I don't
think I showered in the last nine years so I don't think
I've showered in a really long time also this is the I just
realized this is the the main menu that's so fun oh sorry I
just hit my mic that's so fun that's fun okay smelly humans
that's your job tending to us okay wait let me light this
path for you yep where are you I'm lost like what like what
path you're gone Wheatley.
I don't see you.
Oh, there you are.
He's always above me, my little guardian Wheatley.
Okay, we have to split up here for a moment.
Portal up to that passage, and I'll see you on the other
side.
Okay.
Here?
Wait.
This is the right place.
I'm going to get you out of that room.
Oh, okay.
Can you reach that wall back there?
Yep.
Easy.
I'm right here.
Okay, there's another wall over here.
Okay.
Easy.
I'll tell you.
Oh, love them.
Just the way they look is great in their folklore.
Folklore.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, that guy's not active, is he?
Oh, oh, he gets all boxed up.
hope for Christmas.
Now how cute is that?
Now we...
Where are you?
Where are you, buddy-o-pal, friend of mine?
Oh, there you are.
You're not going to tell me to jump.
Right.
Well, I'm going to take this route down the back way.
See you at the ball.
Good luck.
Oh.
Thank you.
Wow, we're actually...
Okay, they're not active.
We're parkouring at the moment.
This is fun.
This is all new and exciting.
Can I bring my own turret home?
And have that guy?
What if I, like, get one, reprogram him to be my bestie?
I know I could just jump there, but I like the long way.
It's kind of fun, too, no?
He didn't see the down-down, right?
Do I need need to go all the way down there?
What's in here?
More lore?
Wait, but then what's down there?
Oh, hold on.
Which comes first?
I love seeing the pink cubes amongst the other ones.
Oh, I thought there was, like, going to be a lore room, you
know?
Okay, okay.
Oh, there we go.
I say lore room, but it's really just, like, madness
scribbles.
But those cool too now.
I like seeing, I like watching the people go mad.
I like watching their descent.
Gladys really fixed this place up.
She also fixed it so quickly.
Like, everything was leaves and now, now there's machines.
It's very cool.
I hate Mondays.
Maybe?
Turret redemption lines, active.
Please do not engage with turrets heading towards
redemption.
Redemption.
Oh, what's that mean?
Actually, I'm trying to figure out where I can portal to.
Don't see it, maybe there?
Turret redemption lines are not rides.
Please exit the turret redemption line.
Oh, it's a red- Oh, this is the redemption line.
Wee!
Everybody, be redeemed!
Be redeemed!
It could be a ride.
Like I said, a Valve theme park would be crazy.
It'd be so fun.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
You.
I'm different.
Thank you.
You're different?
Oh, baby!
Thank you.
I'll take you, I'll take you with us.
Get mad.
What do you mean get mad?
Wait, why are we mad?
Oh, oh, you're okay, you're okay.
I didn't let you go.
I didn't do that.
The game forced me.
Don't make lemonade.
Prometheus was punished by the gods for giving the gift of
knowledge to men.
He was cast into the bowels of the earth and picked by
birds.
Wait, who's shooting at me?
Is there like a little turret jail in there?
Okay, we'll not take you with us because you'll die, so...
Oh, they're testing different guys.
What's happening?
Notes.
Sorry.
Target.
So good?
Watch and learn, everybody.
Watch and learn.
Oh, give it over there.
Yeah, that's worth it.
So what am I, uh, supposed to do here?
What am I, yeah, that's what I'm asking too.
How do I get in there?
So silly.
Oh, wait, I think up here.
Oh, heckin' all.
Wait.
It's a kind of awkward angle.
No can do.
Okay.
Oh.
We missed the... Okay, good.
Clickity click click.
I'm trying to find another wall.
They're like the subtitles and...
that are not in synced at all.
It's kind of funny.
I don't know where to go.
Maybe this?
No?
Down there?
No!
I don't see where I can go.
Was I supposed to go here?
Am I stock?
There's no way.
There's no way I could get stuck.
And I can't get back to where I was.
Oh, jeez.
I can't get a good enough...
I think I'm
just gonna jump.
I'm gonna jump!
Oh.
Oopsie.
Maybe...
I messed up there.
But it feels like that's what I was supposed to do, no?
I feel like that's what I was supposed to do.
Broly the useless punished by the gods for giving the gift
of knowledge to man.
He was cast into the bowels of the earth and picked by
birds.
I mean, this is definitely where I'm supposed to go.
Okay.
No, no, no.
You'll get...
Oh, my buddy.
All right, let's see.
Let's figure this out before I mess it up.
Clickity, click, click.
Oh, I just...
Oh, my gosh.
It's the front of the wall.
Ah, I couldn't...
Oh, my gosh.
Did you see him dance like that?
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, I see it now.
There we go.
It was so easy once I...
Oh, this is the template guy.
Hello.
Template.
You might have been the wrong turret.
Hello.
Live turrets.
They're just shooting them over there.
Hello.
Template.
Oh, brilliant.
You made it through.
Well done.
love this what's that almost there we are is it a real
surprise only the turret control center thank you very much
see that scanner out there right it's deciding which turrets
to keep and which to toss and it's using that master turret
there as a template if we pull out the template turret it'll
shut down the whole production line oh perfect right um i'm
gonna have to hack the door okay so that we can get at it i
believe in you um you'll need to turn around while i do this
Okay, you want me to pull it out?
How?
Oh, there we go.
Well, that should do it.
Template missing.
Continuing from memory.
Oh, hasn't done it?
Oh, right.
Let's figure out how to stop this turret line.
Have you got any ideas?
Any ideas?
Wait, what if we what if we got the guy from from the from
the other side that I you are you still thinking or what's
happening?
No, the one that was that was special.
What if we got him and then?
I'll tell you what, here's a plan.
Let's just both continue contemplating in absolute silence.
No, no, no.
If we put him in there, it'll turn that will be the
template, right?
Hold on.
Can I even still get him?
Where are you going?
Oh, have you got an idea?
Yes, yes, yes, I do!
Response.
I know!
We're gonna make them all so cute!
Wait, but I didn't bring him with me.
Sorry, what's going on over there?
You know I'm rushed over here, still thinking really hard.
Uh-oh, wait.
Can I not go through?
Can I not go back?
But I definitely couldn't bring him with me.
Because it wouldn't, um...
But what we can do is grab one of the defective guys before
he goes into the thing.
They're so annoying.
Okay, maybe I don't want to clone these guys.
Oh, I wish I could have made them the other cute guy.
He was different.
What do you have there?
Hello.
What are you?
Oh, brilliant!
That's brilliant!
Yeah, I know.
I know.
If we're lucky, she won't find out all her turrets are crap
until it's too late.
Classic.
Okay, keep your eye on the turret line.
I'm gonna go and hack the door open.
Oh, wait, I wanna see now.
Okay, I'm about to start hacking.
It's a little bit more complicated than it looked from your
side.
Wait, what'd you say?
It should take about 10 minutes.
Keep one eye on the door.
10 minutes?
actually pretty complicated how long's the door been open I
mean was there any sort of announcement before it opened
like a buzzer or an alarm sometimes or like a aqua alert I
don't know fair enough the important thing is it's open but
it's just mentioned in the future neurotoxin production
employees so let's go and take care of that neurotoxin
generator as well wait how do I how do I go that way or are
we going to go to the adult baby Adult daycare Is this this
it oh So wow they got a printer and everything This is the
adult daycare bring your daughter to work day that did not
end well And 40 potato batteries embarrassing I mean, I
realize they're children, but still, you know, no hanging
fruit or all that Barely sorry wait these definitely look
like they were drawn by like the devs kids or something Oh,
that's so sweet.
Oh, did you guys ever make things like this?
Especially, like, this trifold, like, cardboard, whatever
thing.
For, like, hypothesis and science fair and things.
What's this one?
Electricity from a potato?
Yes, totally.
Wow!
By Alex.
Half-Life Alex?
Wait, but I think Half-Life Alex is spelled with a Y.
But still.
Potato battery?
Not a lemon?
Why are all of these about potato batteries?
Making soda volcano.
Never mind.
Well, you know, at least it's not a potato battery.
I'll give it that.
But it's not terrifically original, is it?
You know what I mean?
Not exactly primary research, even within the child
sciences.
I'm guessing this wasn't one of the scientists' children.
You know, I don't want to be snobby.
But let's be honest, it's got manual laborer written all
over it, hasn't it?
They're not saying they're not as good as the professionals.
You know, they're just a lot dumber.
You are such a hater, Wheatley.
one anything is possible with so i thought that was gonna
say with potato whoa look at the look at that it's growing
right up into the ceiling whoa overrun with potatoes at this
point isn't oh my it's a mutant potato wait yeah i won't
starve i'm gonna use your nuts and bolts as my electricity
I like how you can see my portals all the way over there.
It's cute.
I'm pretty sure we're going the right way, just to reassure
you.
What's over here?
Oh, nothing.
Yeah, we got to stop that neurotoxin, right?
We got this.
Easy peasy.
No worry, I'm absolutely guaranteeing you 100% that it's
this way.
No, it's not this way.
Okay, let's try this one.
Easy peasy.
Oh.
Yip, yip, yipy.
I think this is where we'll call it for this part.
Well, hold on.
I just, like, a little bit ahead.
I just want to see what's...
I knew we were going the right way.
This is the neurotoxin generator.
Bit bigger than I expected.
Not going to be able to just, you know, push it over.
Have to apply some cleverness.
room up at the top so let's go and investigate okay wait is
that it at the bottom the neurotoxin I think it is like a
whole bath of it right cool then I guess in the next part we
will take care of oh I'm already like seeing parts of like
puzzly things.
Ah, I see.
Yes, I'm already seeing puzzly parts that I might need.
And my mind is already already...
Here, let's just go in.
I don't want to stop.
I'm having so much fun.
Why only one hour apart, right?
There's our handiwork.
I should laugh for you.
They do feel pain, of a sort.
It's all stimulated, you know.
But really, enough for them, I suppose.
I think they're having fun.
They're saying hooray and stuff.
I'm afraid the door's locked.
Just checked it.
No way to hack it as far as I can tell.
Mechanism must...
Oh, now look at that.
That's a big laser.
Probably best to ignore it, though.
Just leave it be.
We don't know where those panels it's cutting are going.
Could be somewhere important.
Although, it does give me an idea.
What if we stand here and let them gently...
hub of the laser transport us to a state of absolute
relaxation might help us think of a way it's not much of a
plan if I'm honest but I'm afraid so we got in this point
barring does that even reach it I'm actually not sure all
right so silent contemplation oh my god shut up what are you
doing we don't know what that button shut up shut up shut up
I will have a little rest up here.
In case of implosion, look, directly add implosion.
Wow.
I love when, like, a game makes, like, such a...
What's the word?
Like, a huge...
Like it really shows the scale of an item, you know what I
mean?
Like a setting.
It's so cool.
Just like, wow, it's so big.
A monitor.
Yes, that will be important, I imagine.
I'll keep my eye on that.
Is he actually doing something or?
Or words like password identified or something like that.
Do you smell neurotoxin?
Hold up, the neurotoxin levels are going down so whatever
you're doing keep doing it I did it oh I'm cutting it I'm
cutting it okay is there another you know we'll finish this
thing and then we'll uh I think I need to start from right
way down here though meow meow something's wrong you have
toxic levels up to 50% no it's dang sorry my mistake it
seems dang 50% it's good news carry on did I do it oh
there's another side is it not leaking in here wait is it
not like coming like into going into the room instead
Warning, neurotoxin pressure has reached dangerously
unlethal levels.
Uh-oh!
Really?
Oh!
Ah, the tube's broken!
We could bring it straight to her!
I can't hold her!
Come on!
That was so easy.
Okay.
Yay!
Okay, well, I said I didn't know how long that was gonna
take, but it didn't take any time at all, so...
Once we get to a good point, I will stop it.
I can't believe I'm finally doing this.
Woo!
I knew this would be fun.
They told me it wasn't fun at all until they said it's not
fun at all.
Whoa, getting dizzy.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
This place is huge.
And we're only seeing the top layer.
It goes down for miles.
All sealed off years ago, of course.
We should be getting close.
oh i cannot wait to see everything in here still looks like
new though no turrets she'll never know what hit her unless
she has like all that already i might not have thought this
next part oh i'm going the wrong way get to her i'll find
you okay we're going to glados we're going to glados cool
all right now We'll end it here.
Thank you, guys!
This game is so fun.
I don't want to stop playing, but alas, I must.
So that I can do another part and we can beat the game.
And yeah, it'll be so awesome.
Yuppie!
Thank you so much, everybody, for joining me for part three.
Three of Portal 2.
And I will see you for part four.
Spooky 4 What to meet Oh It's a good day Have a good night
Have a good time And I'll see you Later Bye bye Bye bye